1947 jacques tati tourner les premières
images de jours de fête
le synopsis un petit village français
prépare sa fête annuelle
un manège en bilan sera monté sur la
place et à cette occasion françois le
facteur du village entreprendra une
folle tournée
jacques tati connaît sainte sévère pour
s'y être réfugié en 1943 derrière un
aspect burlesque son cinéma observe la
vie de ses contemporains sainte-sévère
vivait comme beaucoup de villages dans
une relative autarcie petit élevage et
quelques commerces
mais revenons à 2014 où le village
continue de vivre avec d'autres
préoccupations on a un gros souci là les
riverains qui sont ici c'est vrai que
très rapidement les touristes quand il
arrive voyez les véhicules ou est ce
qu'ils sont donc faut qu'on arrive à
organiser ça alexandre stone et déjà
parlé pour françois daugeron et le maire
de sainte sévère
il travaille sur le réaménagement du
centre-ville réunis en plein air avec
ses adjoints et alexandre martin
directeur du centre d'architecturé
d'urbanisme et de l'environnement
on a un grand vide au milieu de la place
et puis moi décidément la le mobilier
urbain devant la maison tati je vais
revenir sous d'anecdotes du mobilier
urbain et une ambiance bon enfant
une vraie problématique sainte-sévère
doit faire face à une nécessaire
modernisation pour rester attractive et
en même temps préserver son patrimoine
un exercice assez difficile c'est
j'avais dire presque un dilemme et pour
ça c'est une autre préoccupation de tous
les jours pour arriver à harmoniser
notre patrimoine et de façon à préserver
tout en ayant des services qui soient
adaptées aujourd'hui et avec de
l'accessibilité tous à ces problèmes dès
des centres bourgs
qui après les faits et cartes postales
qu'on peut tous constaté souligné
apprécié n'attire pas les nouveaux
habitants où même les futurs habitants
parce qu'il ya réellement un problème
d'occupation de l'espace les maisons
sont très imbriquées je pense que là
dessus il faut qu'on agisse de façon
très volontariste un briquet mitoyenne à
coller souvent sur de petites parcelles
les maisons du bourg ne répondent pas
aux besoins d'aujourd'hui le confort
moderne passe par un habitat individuel
entourée d'un jardin est un peu plus
loin des voisins élites ont trop
s'écarter pour avec les terres agricoles
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
préoccupation de prendre des terres
agricoles vers l'extérieur avant on aura
vraiment une opposition forte des
services de l'état il faut plus pour
semer de terres agricoles
et puis le fait de densifier l'activité
en centre bourg contribuer à redonner de
l'animation de la vie moi je pense que
c'est un bon choix
le gros problème est d'ordre urbain et
foncier il faudrait faire en quelque
sorte d remembrement urbain comme on l'a
fait dans le domaine agricole si on
voulait apporter des remèdes à ce genre
de contacts
vivre au village aujourd'hui relève plus
d'un intérêt pour la vie proche de la
compagne que de la nécessité pour
beaucoup de nos grands-parents la vie
rurale s'imposait comme un héritage de
génération en génération
forgeant un vivre ensemble où les liens
entre habitants et des quotidiens et
nombreux ces bâtiments correspondent
plus loire j'ai besoin de recentrer un
peu tout ça dans un lieu commun et
optimiser au maximum
vous savez on est chef lieu de canton
donc on est un village en dessous de
1000 habitants qui a beaucoup
d'infrastructures on a un budget qui
compte quand même contraint et à
s'insérer et notre challenge notre
on veut absolument arriver à stabiliser
la population un de façon à pouvoir
garder tous ses services
conserver les services et les structures
d'accueil agrandir les parcelles dans le
centre-ville maintenir des commerces
voilà le challenge des communes rurales
pour continuer à exister
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui en tant
qu'aménageur aussi bien professionnelles
qu'élu avoir une réponse à court terme
notre rôle c'est de maintenir tant bien
que mal ce qu'elle mérite d'exister et
éventuellement de l'adapter à des
besoins instantané mais je crois qu'il
faut rester très modestes dans les
objectifs on n'aura pas de réponse toute
faite et les magic sainte-sévère à un
atout immortalisée par jacques tati
l'image du village est liée à une
certaine joie de vivre
teinté de nostalgie et ce paysage la
subjectif imaginaire attire